are there
books or movies in your life long ago or
recently
do you have any time for books or movies
had an impact on you
uh what ideas did you take away
i absolutely have time for books and
movies i
try as best i can to not work very hard
um
i mostly fail i should point out but i
think
i'm a better scientist when i don't work
evenings and weekends
i'm if i get four good hours in a day
i often don't i often get eight crappy
hours you know
emails meetings bad code
yes data processing but if i can get
four high quality scientific hours
i just stopped working for the day
because i know it's diminishing returns
after that
so i have a lot of time i try to make as
much time as i can
can you kind of dig into
the what it takes to be one productive
two to be happy in as a researcher
because i think it's too easy in that
world to
to basic because you have so many hats
you have to wear so many jobs you have
to be
a mentor a teacher a head of a
research group do research yourself you
have to do service all the kinds of
stuff you're doing now with education
and
um interviews
yeah yeah yeah so as a a public science
like being a public communicator that's
a job
yeah the whole thing very poorly
i'll pay you in bitcoin okay i'll take
it
uh so uh
is the is there some advice you can give
to
to the process of being productive and
happy
as a researcher i think sadly it's very
hard to feel happy as a scientist if
you're not productive
it's a bit of a trap but it's i
certainly find it very difficult to feel
happy when i'm not being productive
it's become slightly better if i know my
students are being productive
i can be happy but i think a lot of
senior scientists
once they get into that mindset they
start thinking that their student
science
is theirs i think this happens a lot of
senior scientists
they have so many hats as you mentioned
they have to do so much service and so
much admin
that they have very little time for
their own science and so they end up
feeling
ownership over the junior people in
their labs and their groups and
that's really heartbreaking i see it all
the time and
and that i think i've escaped that trap
i feel so happy even when i'm not
productive
when my students are productive i think
that sensation i was describing earlier
they only need to be half as productive
as me for me to feel like
i've done my job for humanity
so that has been the dynamic i've had to
worry about
but to be productive is not clear to me
what you have to do
you have to not be miserable otherwise i
find it extremely hard when i'm having
conflicts with collaborators for example
kind of very hard to enjoy the work we
do even if the work is this
you know fantastical phosphine or things
that i know i love
still very difficult so i think choosing
your collaborators based
on how well you get along with them is a
really
sound scientific choice having a
miserable collaborator
ruins your whole life it's horrible it
makes you not want to do the science it
probably makes you do
clumsy science because you don't focus
on it you don't go over it
several times you just want it to be
over and so
i think in general just not being a
douchebag
can get so much good science done just
find the good people
in your community and collaborate with
them even if they're not as good
scientists as others
you'll get better science out yeah don't
be a douchebag yourself and surround
yourself by other cool people
exactly and then you'll get better
science than if you would
try to work with three geniuses who are
just hell
to be around yeah i mean there's
parallel things
like that i'm very fortunate now um i
was very fortunate at mit
to have friends and colleagues there
that were incredible to work with
but i'm i'm currently sort of
i'm doing a lot of fun stuff on the side
uh like this little podcast thing
and uh i mentioned to you i think
robotics related stuff
um i was at just the boston dynamics
yesterday
checking out their robots
and i'm currently i guess hiring people
to help me with a very fun little
project around those robots
i have more applications i can possibly
deal with there's thousands
so uh it's not that it's the opposite
it's like we need to put an ad
out for someone to help you go through
the applications well that too is
already there
that over ten thousand people apply for
that an infinite mastery of
a dollar of application yeah exactly
management
but the point is it's not it's not
exactly
the point is like what i'm very
distinctly aware of is
life is short and
productivity is not the right goal to
optimize for at least for me
the right goal to optimize for is how
happy you are
to wake up in the day and to work with
the people that you do
because the productivity will take care
of itself great
and so like it's so important to select
the people well and i think uh one of
the challenges with academia as opposed
to sort of the thing i'm currently doing
is
like saying goodbye sometimes a little
bit tougher
because really tough your colleagues are
there or i mean
they're goodbye hurts and then if you
have to spend the rest you know for many
years to come
still surrounded by them in the
community it's tougher it kind of
adds puts extra pressure to stay in that
relationship
uh in that collaborative you know in
that collaboration
and in some sense that makes it much
more difficult but it's still worth it
it's still worth it to break
ties if if you don't
if you're not happy if there's not that
magic that dance i talked to um
there's a guy named daniel kahneman
oh i know danny kahneman danny yeah
boy did that guy make me realize like
what a great collaborator is
well he had tversky right yeah but so
they had obviously they had a really
deep collaboration there but like
i collaborated with him on a
conversation
like just like talking about i don't
know what we were talking about
i think cars autonomous vehicles but the
brainstorming session
i'm like a nobody and the fact that he
would with that child like curiosity
and that dance of thoughts and ideas and
the push and pull and the
like and the lack of ego but then enough
you go to have a little bit of a
stubbornness over an idea and a little
bit of humor
and all those things it's like holy
that person
also the ability to truly listen to
another human
it's like okay that's what it takes to
be a good collaborator
if that makes me realize that i haven't
been i've been very fortunate to have
cool people in my life
but there's like levels even to the cool
yeah i don't think you can compete with
danny cameron on cole he's
just incredible but he was like okay
i guess what i'm trying to say is that
collaboration is an art form
but perhaps it's actually a skill is
allowing yourself
uh to develop that skill because that's
one of the fruitful skills
and and praise it in students you know
and i think it is something you can
really improve on i've become a better
collaborator as the years have gone on
i don't have some innate collaborative
skills i think they're skills i've
developed and i think in science there's
this
really destructive notion of the lone
wolf
the scientist who sees things where
others don't you know then that's
really appealing and people really like
either fulfilling that or pretending to
be fulfilling that
and first of all is mostly a lie
any modern scientist particularly in
astronomy which is so interdisciplinary
any modern sciences do the scientist
says doing it on their own is doing a
crappy job
most likely because you need an
independent set of eyes to help you
do things you need experts in the sub
fields that you're working on to
to check your work but most importantly
it's just a bad idea it's not um
it doesn't lead to good science and it
leaves you miserable
i was recently had some work that i was
avoiding and i thought
maybe i shouldn't pursue the scientific
project because i don't
care enough about the outcome and it's
going to be a lot of hard work and i was
trying to balance these two things
to be really difficult and the outcome
is that maybe 10 people will cite me in
the next decade because it's not
no one's asking for this question to be
answered
and then i found myself working with
this
collaborator jason dipman and i spent a
whole afternoon
hours with him working on this and time
flew by and
and i just felt taller and
like i could breathe better i was
happier i was a better person when it
was done
and that's because he's a great
collaborator
he's just a wonderful person that brings
out
joy out of science that you're doing
with him
and that's really the trick you find the
people that make you feel that way about
the science you're doing and
and you stop worrying about being the
lone wolf
that's just a terrible dream that will
leave you miserable and your signs will
be
and uh since i'm russian just murder
anybody who who doesn't
fall into that beautiful collaborative
relationship
you